ronnie steals a fragment of the rune of  death from malekith and used it to  create the black knives who killed not  only godwin but also provided her with  the means to slay her own empyrean flesh  which removes her from the influence of  the two fingers this was her goal from  the start ronnie did not want to be the  successor of queen marca so she split  herself from it completely see what i  said there split herself this is where i  believe the two sides of the same coin  come back into play for ronnie and  melena they're the same person but with  two different consciousness  consciousnesses  consciousnesses i think that's right